and they've Hatchin what's your job
title I'm just taking a little bit of
time to get into YouTube
you heard about our YouTube incident I
suppose a couple weeks ago quite
impressive but a really good speech
after after you got elected all right
okay Robin are we live Robin you're
muted can't see it yet on I'm making a
fresh in the page currently waiting
pretty car I think I have everyone on my
screen but I just want to check that
you're all happy your end right okay I'm
still can't see it on here but if you
can see it and I'll search again okay
yeah I can see it okay good afternoon
and welcome to start a joint executive
committee the first item on the agenda
is apologies I have no apologies
I will leave through the three
councilors names that on the committee's
they can confirm that they are here
Alyce Caron's did you host president
canceled appalled or not present that's
a filthy alec present second item of
business is to let elected champion
forthcoming year these that I have
nominations thank you sir I'd like to
nominate councillor Paul Arnott from
East Devon and I would certainly like to
second counselor or not you've been let
to chair for therefore mean year so
thank you very much David to you
okay thank you very much welcome to this
Strasser joint executive committee
meeting at Tuesday the 16th of June 2020
we're now on item 3 which is the minutes
of the last meeting which is pages 5 to
8 on your agenda anybody wish to pass
any comments on those with ears
if not are we happy that these are
remotely signed by the chairman Sarah
can you advise to me how we do that if
we if we just it just agree that the
minutes serve true and accurate record
physical signing we will sort out
further down the line to move acceptance
on the minutes chair and second from me
Thank You Phil and Alistair very good
okay now we move on to item four any
declarations of interest and none from
me
Alastair you were there was nothing to
declare there from you either was there
oh no nothing for me so thank you very
much okay thank you very much item five
questions from the public under
procedural rules now I have here noted
at the moment we have no questions from
the public
is that still correct sir no questions
thank you very much and item six is
questions from members of the council
under procedure rules the can I have
that down there's none at this stage is
that okay Sarah yeah let me see thank
you very much in which case we move
straight on to item 7 the IT directors
reports and wishes pages 9 to 34 on your
agenda I'd like to welcome our IT
director Lawrence Whitlock good
afternoon everybody it's Lawrence here
as usual I put together some slides
hopefully you'll be able to see the
slides in front of you at the moment can
everybody see those okay yeah yeah
brilliant and so hopefully everybody
received a copy of the report that the
strata strata managers put together that
we've circulated along with the agenda
for the meeting that goes into a lot of
detail about the last five to six months
of stratas active
and I thought I'd put together some
slides this afternoon - obviously review
some of the work that we've been
undertaking and I think one of the key
things is we want to talk about what
we've been doing over the last sort of
three to four months during the Cova
dinner coded nineteen crisis and how
we've been supporting the authorities so
really a high-level summary of the of
the last sort of three to four months
was very much around the strata systems
being highly available during the crisis
I think one of the things that we've
been working on over the last three
years is ensuring that the systems that
we deliver the support the authorities
predominantly when they're in the office
were highly available and then obviously
when we move to remote working we needed
to ensure that those systems remained
highly available so it's pleased to
report that you know those systems
whether it be global comms global
telephony global desktop or whether it
be the business systems applications
have all been highly available over the
last few months the technology choices
that we made at the outset being based
on a virtualized environment supported
out of our own data centers utilizing a
Skype for business application for
telephony those proves to be very sound
technology choices and I think the
mobilisation of offices to move from a
remote from an office based working
environment or a remote environment was
highly effective in February we went
live with a new portal this was
something Strasser invested in with the
support of the joint exec and joint
scrutiny I think it's fair to say that
portal has enabled us to cope with a
massive amount of demand that's been
coming in to strata in a very scalable
way I think with the old system that we
had in place which was a product called
my support it wouldn't have been able to
cope with that initial demand that was
coming in but now with the new portal
that really our timing couldn't have
been better in actually having that
available in the neighboring users to
access
cause by reporting in by the phone or
via email the resources that we've had
inside strata we feel that have been
flexible we've obviously got about 74 75
people sickness levels are pretty much
non-existent over the last five months
with inside strata and I've certainly
found that all staff have just been
prepared to go that extra mile to
support the work of the three
authorities I think the staff have been
very adaptable no matter what challenges
have been thrown at them they've
literally got on and done what we've
asked of them to do
they've been committed as I said you
know staff absenteeism has been
incredibly low and certainly given that
pretty much day by day changing
environment that has been thrust upon us
we needed to make sure that strata could
support the work of the authorities so
whether it be the community hubs virtual
council meetings I know a number of us
have had conversations about zoom and
Skype and Microsoft teams etc but I
think what is really encouraging is that
we're obviously showing how technology
can support the work of the authorities
and how we can all you know meet in this
virtual environment that were certainly
in this afternoon I think other sound
decisions came from remote access how do
we ensure that people can access the
environment remotely but also in a
secure way so the work we did around
two-factor authentication
actually enabling people not only to
access their IT through work provided
equipment but also on the home IT as
well is testament to some of those
decisions that were made in the very
early stages I think we face some
challenges with Hardware provision as
with a lot of organizations there's been
a need for the provision of hardware to
support remote workers we're quite lucky
we've got a very flexible approach to
Hardware provision we've got a number of
relationships with suppliers and a lot
of them are they've been actually been
able to help us provision IT whether it
be two-factor authentication tokens or
laptops etc we've been able to get those
to actually keep pace with the demands
put on us through by the authorities
but also think we've been pretty much
helping the authorities better inform
some of their citizens of you know the
ways in which they're working supporting
community hubs the work that we've done
around the firm step project with
business grant relief etc it's just
testament to the the skillset that we
have with inside strata so I think from
a high-level point of view it's been
very successful but also when we
actually look at the feedback that we're
getting from our customers ie the users
of the services they've actually been
very complimentary of strata and I think
a lot of businesses always you know they
come to the fore and I think at the
moment I've had so many so much great
feedback from people saying they now
understand what strata is about and how
the global desktop works and how it
actually supports them from a
business-as-usual point of view um I
really wanted to talk about the key
themes that strata have been doing we've
been supporting the work of the offices
really important you know keeping in
ensuring that the offices can deliver
those day-to-day services whether it be
in the office or whether it be remotely
supporting councilors are now in the
early stages there was a lot of talk
about why can't we have zoom etc we had
to do a lot of work on ensuring that
zoom would work with inside the global
desktop environment and maybe it was a
little bit slow to get it up and running
however we wanted to do that for reasons
of scalability flexibility security and
ensuring that we didn't deliver you a
platform that potentially could be
hacked or leave you in a in a difficult
or an embarrassing situation certainly
at times like this when we're actually
live-streaming so we wanted to make sure
that we got that right and we also
wanted to make sure that the technology
we had actually supported the work of
their counselors so at Exeter there was
a lot of issues with the iPads the
number of them were very old we had to
do a lot of work to actually resolve
problems with microphones etc working in
the zoom environment but it's good to
see we are where we are now it's working
well and I think that's testament to
strata the counselors the officers but
it was
Democratic services working very closely
across all three authorities to deliver
the environment that we've got but also
I thought it was very important the
strive to support the citizens whether
it be through our design services
producing documentation leaflets etc to
be able to go out to citizens whether it
be through the work that we do with
firms step etcetera supporting the
citizens we wanted to make sure we were
fleet of foot and agile to actually help
you deliver the services that you needed
to your citizens um if we have a look at
the slide now one of the things that was
very paramount in the very early days
was how quickly could we actually
migrate officers from the office working
environment to a remote working
environment back in March the 25th when
you know lockdown started we had
approximately about 25% remote working
across the authorities so 75% of
officers were still working in out the
office environment over a period of nine
working days pretty much we move from
that 25% on average till about 80 81 82
% of officers working remotely pretty
much fairly painlessly there was
obviously a lot of calls coming in
initially around how do they get their
IT to work how do they do two-factor
authentication but I think this was
testament to the investment that's been
made over five years in that environment
that actually supported that move
towards remote working there's a lot of
organizations who weren't able to move
to remote working and I think you know
this this was you know pretty pretty
sound and these were pretty impressive
figures really and we were monitoring it
on a on a daily basis and sharing that
with the client leads and certainly the
the lines there the Exeter had I think
most people initially working remotely
but then these seven rapidly migrated
people to remote working and team bridge
eventually through moving people towards
working on their own IT were able to get
up to above 70% and I think at the
maximum it was a just over 80%
utilization of people working from their
home environment so I think that was
very good
a lot infirm your users a lot of your
officers were very happy to be able to
work in that safe environment of working
from home we've obviously had to make a
few investments in supporting users what
are the one of the products we bought is
something term TeamViewer that enables
us to get on to not only works PCs I
started provisioned IT but also people's
home PCs and actually helped them
configure their environment to work with
the global desktop so that was a very
sound investment and there's been great
support to the service desk with
everybody moving to a a home working
environment we are dented very early on
that the internet provision into the
strata data centers needed to be
increased one of our concerns in the
early days was with the emergence of
video conferencing video utilizes a high
amount of Internet bandwidth we needed
to put into place very early on a
flexible bandwidth model that enabled us
to move from the existing 400 Meg of
Internet provision up to one gig of
Internet provision now we did that
working in partnership with Virgin Media
who provides the internet provision and
whereas you know three four weeks ago
when we would go when we were starting
to deliver the the zoom environment we
were seeing the internet cap pretty much
being hit even with low volume users of
calls we found that once we increase to
the one gig we've got much more Headroom
much more capacity to actually support
the need for zoom meetings team meetings
and Skype meetings etc so that again
shows that we you know we're pretty
fleet of foot in being able to you know
increase that bandwidth and I believe we
were also able to do it in a very
cost-effective way to the council's as
well obviously we talked earlier on
about systems availability on a monthly
basis we report using the radar diagram
on the availability of the strata
services from the center point it's 95
percent availability I I've just put in
there a double-headed arrow that shows
that during the kovat nine
in crisis the availability of the strata
systems have been a grub 99.5% though I
know last month during the month of
sorry April it was 100% availability
last month I think was about 99.95
percent availability so high
availability of the systems and that's
measured over a 24 by 7 window as well
we did have an issue very early days
this is the Civic Center we have a
backup generator in the Civic Center
Adrian the team noted that there was an
issue with the existing generator we
were concerned that should we lose mains
power into the Civic Center we would
lose our primary door we could
potentially lose our primary data center
as the generator we had could not cope
with just over 50% capacity we had to be
proactive so Adrian brought in a backup
generator just on the off chance that we
lost the primary feed into the office
fortunately we didn't but the good thing
is we needed to ensure that we had that
resiliency in place a relatively
low-cost investment over a three week
window of time whilst the original
backup generator was actually being
maintained and fixed so again you know
group that we had those sort of
relationships that we can bring in
equipment like this to ensure that
resiliency of the IT environment that
everybody was so hugely dependent on a
very busy site here but basically sort
of saying three things number one in the
top left hand corner is with the Nuvi
fire application we've now been able to
automate a lot of the processes so each
of those little windows there is you
click on a window and you ask for an
using new user to be set up and those
forms behind them that enables us to
actually put a process behind a number
of the actions that we take whether this
is setting up new generic email
addresses for things like the community
hub site they can all be done by the V
fire application over on the right hand
side is the BCR
and it came the time of year where we
normally get quite a lot of VCRs coming
in for obviously ended year processing
but we saw quite a dramatic rise in the
number of VCRs coming in to strata
historically we have about 200 BC ours
in the in the system at any one time
at the end of May we had gone up to 430
BC ours so we had almost doubled the
amount of work with inside the strata
businesses or with inside all strata
teams we'd also seen a massive rise in
the number of service requests coming in
whether this be for the provision of
two-factor authentication whether it be
for the provision of zoom Microsoft
teams or whether it just be yo incidents
helping people actually get their IT
working so again the slide down the
bottom sort of shows those levels of
incidents and that is increased quite
considerably over the last sort of 12
weeks but it's at a level now that we
manage it on a daily basis we have we
have calls where we actually go through
all the incidents BC ARS problems and
and service requests and we're not
seeing now an increase and we're
actually starting to work those those
levels of demand are starting to drop I
mentioned earlier on about obviously
supporting the work of the authorities
we have a team of specialists working
with the authorities for creating the
firm step forms to actually deliver
business support grants so therefore
we've got the teams at team bridge at e7
who are allocated obviously working with
Exeter as well to actually put the forms
in place to test the prog forms and
deploy the forms to enable you to
actually give out those grants to
businesses and citizens we did a lot of
work in the early stages around setting
up and community hubs a really important
function of the authorities many
technology choices that you made in
Skype for business enabled those to be
set up relatively painlessly we also
have the ability to create the forms to
help people communicate
with the authorities by the community
hubs and I think that proved very
successful in the team's actually being
able to mobilize and take something that
was a real critical nature and actually
put the systems in place to support your
work without it taking you know a huge
amount of time to deliver some of these
requirements
zooom we mentioned zoom earlier on that
is one of the earlier calls for East
Evans probably some familiar faces there
I think counsel Anna you're on there
again this was a big challenge I
mentioned earlier on we needed to make
sure it worked in a highly scalable way
and that the officers could join the
calls as well as the counselors I know
the counselors were using zoom
extensively for their own meetings but
we needed to make sure that when
officers started to help and manage and
oversee some of those meetings happening
certainly when they start to get
broadcast we needed to make sure that
the bandwidth was available that the IT
supported it and that we had trained the
users so we really took three of our
staff so Clyde Newton who I'm sure most
people know who joined us a year ago now
as our IT trainer who was fantastic in
actually working with all the
authorities Pete Jones is on the call
this afternoon leading that team along
with Robin to actually deliver this zoom
functionality and I think it now seems
to be using being used very widely
across the authorities for delivery of
council meetings we did it utilizing pay
for zoom licenses because it was
perceived that there were some security
flaws with unpaid-for licenses but I
think we've landed in a good place now
we also did a lot of work around helping
the authorities communicate with their
citizens at East Devon we produced
working in conjunction with the officers
at East Evan a community back that got
distributed so that was created by our
design team and actually got distributed
out to the citizens of East Devon a very
informative guide so again we did a lot
of work on actually helping the
authorities deliver these important
messages and but also we've had a lot of
work going on in the background it's not
just about Kovac 19:00
there's about
67 projects in flight some of them
covert related a lot of them are
projects that have been going on for
some time prior to Co vid Pete Johns has
taken up the role of the head of IT
solutions delivery joining the strata
management team Pete was instrumental in
delivery of the Skype for business
project over the last over two to three
years Pete's now leading on utilizing
the project framework that David circum
and his team put into place Pete's now
heading that up making sure that
framework becomes the de facto standard
for how we deliver our projects moving
forward
we're now able to drill much more into
the detail of projects and the graph in
the bottom left hand corner shows that
at the present time there's a lot of
projects in the implementation phase so
you know there's not that many projects
that have not started we got visibility
there's some that are that are at the
business case stage some that are open
starting to go through bickerman but
there's a big spike at implementation
there's very little in the way of
transition at the moment so once we
finish the implementation phase we move
through to transition but Poots also
working very closely to actually close a
lot of the projects down that have have
been at that transition stroke ready to
close stage but we're actually going to
be closing them down the projects are
pretty evenly shared across the
authorities the graph on the right hand
side shows how the projects are split
but Pete's obviously been involved very
much on the virtual council meetings
since he took up of the role on the 1st
of April but he is now starting to work
much more to deliver this project
framework and to keep the authorities
much more informed about the project
lifecycle and project process customer
satisfaction is very important to us we
measure it on every call when we when we
have a call when we close the call we
ask for feedback it's very encouraging
we changed the mechanism we just used to
base it on a happy smiley face and you
know
add face or something in between we've
now got more granularity in the
reporting that we asked for
so whether people were happy with the
communications that came through strata
through the process of dealing with a
call and it's very encouraging the the
looking at the the four questions that
we asked and also looking at the scores
we're actually seeing a high level of
customer satisfaction across all three
authorities and certainly is improved
month by month as the new v5 platform
gets embedded and people get used to the
familiarity of the questions we're
asking we have seen a drop in the amount
of feedback that we're getting but we're
finding a lot more value from that
feedback we go we're starting to look at
how that feedback is gathered and where
we put the questions on the on the
closure document so hopefully we can
start to drive up the level of feedback
that we're receiving but we understand
that given where we are now we're
starting to see a potential change in
the way the authorities need strata to
be working and some of the things that
you know 11 12 weeks ago weren't really
on the or we're on the agenda but were
sort of we were working through over the
next or the 12 months have really very
much come to the fore now people being
able to collaborate we know that
Microsoft teams because it's a
replacement for Skype for business by
2025 we know that's probably going to be
very much on the agenda there certainly
seems to be a desire to move towards
teams we would be looking at that to
coexist initially with the Skype for
business platform we're starting to
increase our own knowledge and awareness
of teams we've got a big project
underway a migration to Windows 10 that
will be needed to enable us to move over
onto Microsoft teams and that we see as
part of a collaboration toolkit that
we're going to be delivering we've done
quite a lot of work over the last few
months or on dashboards power bi etc a
lot of the reports that I produce
come out from the dashboards that David
and these team have created we sat down
or we had a workshop with the with the
chief execs and the client leads last
Thursday and we started to look through
some of these new priorities and
corporate dashboards was very much up
there where's the data to start advising
the councilors and advising the officers
how their individual departments but
also how the authorities are performing
so we're going to be doing a lot more
work around there but also then there's
one of channel shift as well you know a
lot of use is now used to like to come
or citizens like to come into the office
like to like to phone up the office but
people are now actually starting to
realize that actually they're much more
familiar and a lot happier to deal in a
digital way and certainly at the
workshop we held on Thursday it's
seeming that enabling people to interact
with the authorities in the more digital
way is very much going to be the shape
of things to come so again these were
three areas that we saw us needing to
focus in on and us needing to
potentially consider solutions and maybe
accelerate some of the programs of work
that enables us to deliver some of these
requirements that maybe were there but
we're not there at the level that they
are now 11 12 weeks ago so really I had
you know flew through you know what
we've been up to within strata I
personally very proud of what everybody
is achieved within so strata I couldn't
ask any more from any of my teams the
managers have been brilliant
in supporting the work of the
authorities has anybody got any
questions at all about what we've been
up to oh and I'll stop screen sharing
thank you I'll come in it's Paul here
I'm coming hopefully Lawrence a great
report thank you so much for that I
don't think I may only be asking for
myself and I have tried to look up the
acronym BCR by googling I've got the
City Rollers review I've what is it
right Jesus this change request so that
is where somebody was to be made to a
system and it goes through a formalized
process to actually deliver that change
thank you
the problem feel alistair be questions
yeah I certainly have a few things you
talked about the bandwidth and I we I
see from the global desktop zoom is now
being put on there when I used it the
other day the picture is still very
pixelated is that the phrase to use and
so for instance on this occasion I'm
coming in through my own I've got my own
laptop I'm coming in through use the ID
and the password incoming that way it's
still a little bit unreliable is what I
would say I know a dream would you sorry
we do like that answered first yes so
yes we are doing something about that I
see is the answer you know I I report
what's wrong with my car that don't mean
to say I need to understand it when they
put it right afterwards and so that's
very good the the other thing Microsoft
teams you know you're busily on your way
there I do hope you're gonna have a
conversation with us before you start
and putting this all over onto onto that
until team start catching up with zoom
to be quite honest is my my view about
that so I can understand it but I still
think you know I I don't want a
presentation this is a far better
presentation if you don't want to mean
and so if I was in a meeting I'd be able
to see everybody I can see everybody in
this meeting as well so that's very very
important and then the other thing is
about I mean obviously is the as a
leader of the council I had the ability
within my global desktop to arrange
appointments and also to have Skype
invites to meetings as counsel do I get
such a facility on do I have somebody
else I'm quite happy to go through our
PA team if they've got the facility to
arrange meetings these are very very
important sort of facilities for us as
leaders to be able to say you know right
I'm calling a meeting maybe I want a
meeting with the portfolio older and a
couple of other people on skype on on
zoom' I need to be able to do it so
that's the other thing and my final
thing is a little request is there any
particular for the global desktop which
may help presentation is there any
particular standard of camera that we
should use on our machines which may aid
a thing if you understand what I mean so
those three sort of issues there that if
I could be dealt with Paul do you wanna
come back done those Laurence that's
already just knows it them I think I
think probably this this is a good forum
as we're all on up we've got the
technical expertise we've got Adrian
Robin and and Pete who have been pretty
much involved in it in this project so I
don't know which one of you I'm sure
you'll all come up with exactly the same
message so you want to take that well
hang hang hang on a sec then let's do
one I'll come to Alastair in just a
second yeah so we've we've got the
questions out there I would suggest that
my experience and our experience and
zoom has been best than teams sorry if
that's difficult but I wonder whether
what might be a good idea is to just
canvas the members who've who've been
your customers for the last 12 weeks
doing this and been enjoying it and I
think maybe let's have a look and see
what the feedback is from from
counsellors perhaps
before you go too far on that I think
one of the things we we probably need to
be careful of teams is more than
videoconferencing zoom is a great video
conferencing platform I think we've
proven it this afternoon I think all
that strata would agree the whole
experience of teams of zoom has been
very very positive
however teams offers a lot more in the
way of collaboration desktop sharing
document sharing etc so I think you know
we have to be careful that we're not
comparing apples with pears you don't
mind that terminology is that actually
Microsoft probably understand that they
they missed the mark with teams from a
video conferencing point of view video
conferencing was part of Skype but up
till about 12 weeks ago it wasn't
necessarily the be-all and the end-all
of the Skype platform and Microsoft have
not really invested a huge amount of
video conferencing
I think they've seen over the last 12
weeks that they've missed a massive
opportunity and now they are trying to
play catch-up with zoom and given the
might of Microsoft and their investment
I think we will see Microsoft putting a
huge amount of money into video
conferencing so um I take onboard
everything you've said I think it
probably Microsoft will not be where
zoom are for at least the next 6 to 12
months
I think the zoom experience and Robin
Adrienne P feel free to interject but I
think we will be utilizing zoom
certainly for the forseeable stroke
medium future certainly up till April
next year and probably beyond where zoom
will still be being used but I think we
will see Microsoft investing a lot of
money in the technology to get this
working as well as this zoom platform ok
so it's not so before we throw to the
other guys can we just um Alistair sorry
I know you've got your blue hand up
there Thanks thanks very much Paul
yeah and I'll just take it down if I can
and so I wanted to also talk about zoom
Skype and of course other things like
Cisco
webex because as I understand it most
big organizations are using Cisco WebEx
as a much more secure platform than than
any of the others and and again it's a
platform that works unlike teams and you
only have to see the Fiasco this morning
at County when we're trying to get a
Stephan's chairman to speak to us and
shake and wave our hands about and all
the rest of it but certainly no sound at
all coming through and and and the
staggering amount of bandwidth that
teams use is just to get about four
people's images up speaking so so I mean
I think in one sense I understand why we
didn't spend much time on on having web
conferencing and but I know at County
Hall as chair of their counselors
standing over view group looking at what
we're trying to do in terms of the
environment and our environmental
challenge to get to carbon neutral by
2030 I could not believe that it was
almost impossible to have a meeting that
didn't involve a dozen councilors
driving from one side of Devon to the
other to hold a meeting in County Hall
when everybody else was running online
online meetings so so you know I think
you've done very well to get things
going but I think in all honesty we
should have been a further ahead on on
the curve and and I know we all love
zoom and and spend all our days on it so
that your eyes at the end of the day are
popping out but but certainly I you know
my son who works in in an online
business you know they quite regularly
have team meetings involving 500 600 700
people on Cisco WebEx and
and and in fact they have whole company
meetings occasionally on it and and and
and that works really well and is really
stable as far as skype is concerned one
of the things that I found I have Skype
meetings with with team bridge officers
and none of them have cameras so I
really don't see the point of having a
Skype meeting when frankly you could
just have a conference telephone call
and and quite how we thought we would
actually hold council meetings on skype
I'm not sure but certainly why don't
team bridge officers have cameras so
that that's that's my first thing I'm
pleased to see that you're using team
TeamViewer but but I you know it's
hardly new technology and then on page
15 you talked about the the problems of
using internet viewers and I'm wondering
why you're not considering Firefox from
the Mozilla Foundation I mean that is
one of the one of the few things that
one can actually say does work at Devon
County and and that's that's I think
something that we should we should
consider and certainly the Mozilla
Foundation is something I think that we
should support as as a group of councils
because they have really good sort of
basis fought for their constitution and
then the final thing it was was bringing
in the the business about agendas
because for most councillors that
they're basically operating out of one
iPad and if you're operating out of an
iPad you then can't see the agenda and I
we should be thinking about going back
to having
paper agendas for council meetings just
so that people can can actually operate
and then just one one final thing that
Phil mentioned he's on the global
desktop I think I'm the only team bridge
counselor who actually has access to the
global desktop but I have to say I
haven't bothered with it because the
thought of logging in and the slowness
and the fact I can't print anything and
and yeah it's just it's just just way
too slow so I'm not really quite sure
whether the global desktop is relevant
for councillors okay I am if it works I
don't just say Hollister if it works I
wouldn't be able to do my council
leaders job without the global desktop
if you use it I've got two screens my
own screens the printer you can get it
all connected up quite easily and you
clearly understand these things I
would've thought you you you you imagine
I can't get it to print in the thing but
anyway I'm sure that I'm fairly certain
that Gordon isn't using it because he
has difficulty using his iPad anything
else just before we throw back to
Lawrence just between the three of us if
I put a proposition to you I just wonder
how you feel which is that certainly the
majority of our members I mean this is a
you know on the straw poll very much
want us to continue to have a facility
to meet virtually into the permanent
future and so obviously there's going to
have to be government legislation you
know yeah resmoke making involves all
this kind of stuff but I suppose the
question therefore I mean do you agree
with that feel as well is that what
you'd like to see well there will be
there will be as much as I like driving
to team bridge or indeed he's Devon I
think there are some merit in doing in
doing this there will be the time that
we need to come together and I think
that that's a debate I'd be happy to
have you know with you is
and leaders on the way forward I think
that would be appropriate but you know
this let's get the technology going it
is helpful but there is something about
having no proper meetings the world of
zoom yeah it's okay but yeah I don't
know what government are going to do at
the end of the day Paul I suppose always
think about the this goes from parish to
town councils to our level and above is
when you've got the elderly protected
but may go on for years you certainly
got young parents who are unable to
stand for election even because they're
having trouble getting to meetings
yeah he just looks to me as if there's
an opportunity here if it's easy to do
without it seeming to Doctor Who if we
can have a screen in a room with a chair
and the majority of members in
attendance
I think I think I think you're right I
agree that's something that we're gonna
have to look to for the future for
instance we have a lot of meetings where
people visit us I think all those sort
of business meetings will now be a
virtual in my view and you'll only ever
come together when you actually come to
formally sign a deal off or sign those
papers let's just say you're doing a big
development project you'll do a lot of
this and then you know people won't be
coming down from London every other day
I think what they'll do is they'll come
down or we'll go up for the one sort of
pull it all together mean I think that's
the way it's gonna go in yeah we've
actually put on to the agenda very much
the hybrid meeting I think it's
inevitable but that's the way people
want it to be people want to be able to
join a meeting in person we're in the
virtual world and the systems can
accommodate that we've just got to make
sure that as you say the technology is
easy to use that you know everybody can
become a counselor should they want to
become a counselor just because they you
know they don't want to drive it
shouldn't rule them out from being a
council I know I think we we we call it
that start the hybrid virtual meeting of
that combination of both and I know
that's very much on the offices agenda
and it's something that Robin Adrian MP
have been
talking about it about when does this
come in we're also we're obviously
looking towards the government to see
you know what are they going to be doing
how are they going to you know
facilitate that change are they going to
force all votes to be done in person or
will they be happy for votes to be done
in the theatre world yeah you know -
because I'm just as guilty I've worked
it out this meeting will be due to
finish in about quarter past eight if we
take each I'm just just saying I I've
got a bubble at 6 o'clock we can go
[ __ ] boss bash and get the next
question was Lawrence did you feel did
you take a note of any of the questions
from Phil and from Alastair that you
feel like think between the management
team we've got a pretty good idea and we
could respond back to those questions
that have been raised and I think
they're all very very valid questions as
well so yeah it's more than happy to
respond back on those Paul can I can I
just come in were you proposing that we
actually take what you said a bit
further in the sense that in my view we
should be writing to to the Secretary of
State and and putting our view that this
needs to carry on that we can't just go
back to the to the terrible ways that we
were of driving all around the
countryside I got I sit on one committee
at County Hall which often lasts no more
than 20 minutes and and we all of us
drive from all romic all round Devon for
to sit there for 20 minutes it's just
ridiculous no well let's pick that up
let's pick that up between ourselves I
think is the answer good
we've got a funky new portfolio holder
for democracy and transparency who want
to drive that along as well I'm sure
we'd say who's next sir
so doesn't contact me then please yes
yeah I'll Drive it in temperature good
good so Lawrence do you feel you
crack of the whip there I would like to
feel we have it's very positive taking
obviously the comments on board
regarding team zoom etc yes we will
obviously the next time we meet I'm sure
it will still be over zoom and I hope
they'll be as successful as this cause
the other point I'm happy to note the
report chair yeah and thank you very
much thank you thank you
right so if we move on to item 8 strata
budget monitoring page 35 268 can I
welcome Dave Hodgson please thank you
care as an accountant I can show you
that I will bring you back on track on
time this is the out turn position for
strata reporting out our year-end
financial results so if we just popped
page 36 you'll see a table at the top
which summarizes the business plan and
the projected revenue savings for strata
and against that the actual revenue
savings delivered to date so I'm please
saying in 2019-20 we've returned in two
tranches over a million pounds to the
three owner councils as members will
recall we reduce the initial bills by
half a million pounds to strata and then
we've delivered a leap from at the end
of the financial year five hundred and
seventy three thousand that's about two
hundred and twenty thousand above what
we projected in the business plan and
the reasons for that increase is set out
in Section three point two at the bottom
of page 36 and and just going over on to
page 37 also in the report
there's the draft annual report and
financial statements so these are the
financial statements based on on
popular counseling practice I'm pleased
to report but as up today I have
received the final statements from
Francis Clarke who are our external
auditors and they will be going to the
Board of Directors on Friday for
approval there's no changes to the
numbers from those set out in the report
just a little strengthening of that the
going concern and going concerns an
issue for strata because normally a
company with a negative balance sheet
wouldn't be viable and our viability
relies on the guarantee from the three
owners in relation to the pension fund
and please say from a statutory
accounting point of view our financial
position has actually improved and if we
go to page 52 which is the balance sheet
you will see we've had a seven hundred
fifty thousand pound improvement in the
value of the company it's now a negative
five point three six million pounds but
I would note that the the net pension
liability because strata officers are
parts of the local government defined
benefit scheme and the net pension
liabilities five point nine million so
if that didn't exist for strata we would
actually be quite a healthy company and
I'm happy to take any questions okay
thank you very much mr. or Phil any
questions yeah yes please thanks Paul
and I just wanted to say I absolutely
and and the accounts look look really
great
I I did just sort of pick up one sort of
thing that I genuinely don't understand
on page 54
he says the depreciation is 1.09 1
million but on page 61 it says the
depreciation is one point five five six
million
and and I just wondered why there's the
discrepancy on that but other than that
well done Dave do you want so that one
I'm gonna blame my external auditors
like a good accountant always does so so
actually Frances Clark prepare the
statement of accounts on our behalf and
they prepare the cash flow statement
so Alistair I will go back to it Frances
bar and just get their their
confirmation oh did you say on page 61
the depreciation is one point five five
six yeah let me just pull up 61
yeah depreciation has that first of
april 2019 1.55 six million yet so so
the figure in page 56 is depreciation
and amortization for this financial year
yeah
depreciation and amortization the pick
the figure on on page 56 page 61 you
have a depreciation amount of one point
five five six going to one point seven
seven three by the end of the financial
year and then there should also be a
note for amortization on the preceding
page page six date which shows a
movement from 2.5 to 3 point 1 million
and it should be the the difference in
the end of those two figures should
equate to the figure in the cash flow
statement okay chair unprepared to
subject to the clarification and that
we've just add in fact can be militant
chair happy to knock the reporter based
upon their thank you do we have a
seconder for that I'll second it thank
you I step okay that's patoot lee noted
thank you very much thank you Dave
so now we come to part 2 of the meeting
which is items suggested for discussion
and public excluded so I need a proposer
and a second to go into okay yes I need
to wait about 30 seconds before I turn
the YouTube off and then so if they're
probably be a down time of about a
minute so I need to wait 30 seconds and
I need it
not on YouTube but watching YouTube at
the moment but I can't turn it off until
such time as I know they've seen your
vote to go into party okay we'll wait
for you thank you whilst we're waiting
can I ask Dave why there's being such a
large increase in debtors on page 61
please so better